yeah hello and welcome to see your plane
big wh let's go for double of yunkai oh
he's going for Greenfeld Slav hybrid
this line is played quite often she's
not willing to spend even half a second
per move
well it is very solid to like set up
zone there's nothing particularly
challenging at this point that needs to
be considered thoroughly sound playing
quickly is probably okay yeah b5 I
usually think is a strategic mistake in
such a position as b5 will be a weakness
however here taking is not super
convincing for me relay SES is tempo I
still probably have to take I don't
really see a huge alternative them okay
yeah we'll see one
Queen b6 you always have to watch out
for potential nigt force and so on
there's no tactic here but sometimes
with the Queen only success is getting
getting interesting okay so don't not
quite sure what he what he is up to
I said move doing ninety five point
three five and totally certain I had
DeForest Knight b6 that is probably not
leading to anything
yeah
and some really nothing special
hmm it's interesting move I that I did
not anticipate unfortunately
where he three is okay you know I mean
I'm not in trouble but I did not see
this beforehand Bishop h6
you know he's starting to think before
that he was just like dashing out moves
okay yeah I don't know I don't know the
the point or anything might be six you
never get anywhere with black at the end
of all this I want to put a knight on c3
and win the b5 pawn that is the problem
of the b5 move some moves earlier it's
something that it's not felt immediately
but it is a long-term thing now I'm
threatening nothing I thought I was
threatening you forward okay he's got
this check now and I overlooked this
entire limb it is very silly
very silly yeah now this is good no this
is quite good
I can do this stone I mean
and maybe I'm actually okay even though
I overlooked some stuff I mean black had
some moves and that were just not
strategically right this is why I'm
slightly annoyed by this whole thing
hopeful thing um but the ship do you
mourn and we should be two wins the
Queen
I mean he took half for half a second
per move in the opening this is a real
pet peeve of mine if people do that I'm
always like red flags
want to win now is queenís trapped
I mean okay played all this like yet 3.8
at the clock at this point I mean I also
had this but I had this on the board a
million times some anyway so he went b5
which i think is strategically a mistake
maybe nothing too serious maybe but I
just don't believe it as a good idea to
begin yourself so I took it the engine
doesn't like the system interesting just
wants to play Bishop g2
okay so Queen B 1 and now if yeah maybe
I'm not better here one thing that I
absolutely did not see when I was going
for this was this Bishop h6 thing there
was a real problem Queen b6 Queen a
jewel and now yeah instead of age 5
again immediately played Bishop h6 would
have been a problem yeah if I have to do
this
as the engine suggests then I definitely
have no way frontage yeah so b5 I
probably have to have to answer
differently Queen b3 a like after intern
suggestion him but okay so he went to
age 5 I played Age 3 and Bishop h6 would
have been stronger wit okay it was not
relevant he was just playing instantly
anyway and now he finally found this
idea yet is not as strong as it was
before
yeah no this is not so great iam d4
d44 black really okay yeah yeah 95 93
that is an idea definitely me I
definitely miss played at them I still
don't like b5 but I answered it
completely in a completely wrong way
yeah and here this is this whole thing
it's just not not great due to this this
queen c6 thing Queens the six now I
don't did not see that at all
I mean at all the engine wants to go
deform here aged form was the strong
move it seems f4 takes here black has a
key advantage that F feel is quite
remarkable
hey Kenan I can absolutely not move I
have nowhere to put this and he's got
Quincy three coming wow that would have
been terrible absolutely terrible and
here after F war he probably has to do
something I mean I'm not actually
threatening to take this as DG was
hanging he has to take a moment and
consider this nothing just loses more or
less and he just has 98
I didn't even spot that it's really hard
I know I'm still not in good shape and I
was sick the whole week and now I'm
feeling better
like you know since yesterday morning
it's better but still not really working
properly he also didn't spot that you
can just move this piece of course I
mean black is is worse but it's nothing
since not lost he just just gave me the
Queen okay guys thanks for watching